for months pundits have been predicting
a rise in anti-establishment parties
ahead of the EU elections ever once they
were right
but across the block in the weeks
leading up to the vote panic was setting
in and let's be clear that panic wasn't
without ground scandals emerged or
reemerged in a timely fashion take
marine lepen days before france headed
to the polls the EU's top court ordered
her to pay back 300,000 euros to the
European Parliament this followed a case
in which the national rally leader had
been accused of paying in aid
incorrectly but the timing felt off it
was almost as if it was a way to tell
voters that her party just couldn't be
trusted that came hot on the heels of
accusations that former Trump
strategists Steve Bannon was actually
the one pulling all lepen strings yet
the public didn't seem to care and the
national rally still topped the polls
here in France are the scandals that
were rife in the media included one
about the Russians well at least the
alleged Russians no shock there but of
course not a single troll in sight it
was of course
Austria's FPO the party which was in
coalition with Sebastian Kurtz People's
Party found itself under the spotlight
not for its potentially dubious policies
but for a good old cash for influence
gambit
[Music]
there was even an attempt to drag the
pens name into IB thir gate as it became
known a few months ago marine lepen was
singing the praises of Austrian Vice
Chancellor Heinz Cristina Strucker
saying how formidable he was Strucker
has been forced to resign we find out
why he was caught trying to sell his
services to foreign forces behind this
nationalist movement is a submission to
foreign forces despite this the FBO
still managed to pick up just over 17
percent of the vote in Austria there was
also of course the elections very own me
to moment one Swedish Democrats
candidate accused the other of sexual
harassment and even though the scandal
washed away it didn't hamper the
anti-immigration party's performance
they increased their share of the vote
to more than 15% and despite Merkel
microrna terror warning that populist
parties wanted to destroy Europe we are
having to deal with populist movements
that in many areas are contemptuous of
our values and want to destroy the
Europe of the values we represent we
have to stand up to this these parties
significantly increase their
representation in many parts of the EU
sex money the long arm of Washington
reaching for control in Europe nothing
seemed to put
voters off seeking something new what is
clear from the results of these
elections is that the old guard can no
longer count on the masses to support
them in blind faith what Europeans want
is something different it seems
regardless of what that is Charlotte
dubitzky
RT Paris
you